le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais comment devenir
accueillant familial c'est quoi
l'accueil familial est une solution
intermédiaire entre le maintien à
domicile
l'hébergement en établissement il permet
d'accueillir au sein de son foyer
une personne âgée et ou adultes
porteuses d'un handicap
moyennant une rémunération ce dispositif
est une activité réglementée par le code
de l'action sociale et des familles et
placés sous le contrôle du conseil
départemental
ce dispositif est une compétence
obligatoire du département
à qui s'adresse-t-il si vous êtes majeur
ou en couple et que vous souhaitez
accueillir une des personnes âgées et ou
adultes porteuses d'un handicap adressé
une demande écrite à la présidente du
conseil départemental
pour tout renseignement vous pouvez
contacter la direction des personnes
âgées et handicapées au 02 62 90 35 58
ou rendez vous sur www.cglpl.fr rubrique
social accueil familial
l'accueillant familial recevoir une à
trois personnes à temps complet ou
partiel
cette formule originale qui met fin à l'
isolement d'un public vulnérable
constitue une priorité du conseil
départemental
l'agrément est délivré par le conseil
départemental pour une durée de cinq ans
et
mais